commençons donc si vous voulez bien par
évoquer cette manifestation qui aura
lieu dimanche à paris contre
l'islamophobie ses organisateurs en
temps de défendre la population
musulmane contre la stigmatisation dont
elle est ou dont elle serait l'objet
c'est une très mauvaise idée pensent
certains qui estiment que c'est une
sorte de d'encouragement au
communautarisme
alors avant que vous lui donnez votre
point de vue je vous propose d'en
écouter trois d'abord d'un responsable
politique favorable à cette initiative
c'est alexis corbière le député de la
france insoumise de seine saint denis
dans notre émission auditions publiques
rassemblons nous faisons preuve de
fraternité les musulmans ne sont pas
loin de là et bien de la même façon que
quand il ya des moments où il ya des
crimes antisémites dans le pays je pense
qu'il faut sortir dans la rue pour dire
non à l'antisémitisme
il ya eu des deux il nous semble utile
et voici maintenant deux autres points
de vue d'abord celui de brice hortefeux
député européen les républicains il
était ce matin sur europe 1 et pour lui
si il y à une manifestation
elle doit s'opposer où elles devraient
s'opposer à tous les actes anti
religieux quel qu'il soit il s'y lie à
une marche qui devait être organisée moi
je serais pour qu'il y ait une marque
contre toutes les agressions à l'égard
de toutes les religions
voilà et puis enfin une dernière prise
de position celle de jean michel
blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
c'était chez notre consoeur caroline
roux sur france 2 lui est contre cette
initiative notamment parce que les
organisateurs se critique dans un texte
les lois liberticides et parmi ces lois
il y aurait même si elle n'est pas cité
nommément la loi interdisant le port du
voile pour les élèves de l'enseignement
secondaire loi à laquelle jean michel
blanquer air est très attaché que c'est
lamentable tout simplement une façon de
lutter contre la laïcité en utilisant
des arguments
qui ne valent pas chacun est libre
d'adhérer à une religion de la critique
et c'est justement ça aussi la adrien
theaux qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi
est-ce-que manifestations comme celle là
divise à ce point alors c'est avant tout
à cause des initiateurs de la pétition
enfin dans la tribune qui est paru dans
libé et qui annonce la manifestation
puisqu'il ya parmi ses initiateurs il ya
le ccf ainsi que la plateforme les
musulmans qui sont ccf collectif contre
l'islamophobie oui oui qui sont en fait
des appendices des frères musulmans en
france qui sont en tout cas sur les
positions idéologiques des frères
musulmans qui sont controversés donc il
ya ça il ya aussi les signataires c'est
à dire qu' un certain nombre de
confrères ont dit qu'il y avait une
polémique sur nadéra bouazza ce qui est
un imam salafiste qui s'est depuis
retiré mais ce n'est pas que si on a des
rabots anas nous mariam on a un petit
peu regardé et des dizaines de gens qui
sont des intégristes qui sont des gens
qui sont contre l'égalité hommes-femmes
et de manière virulente parfois jusqu'à
justifier le viol des femmes qui ne sont
pas voilées qui sont contre liberté de
conscience et c'est donc il ya ça les
signataires y les initiateurs il ya
aussi le contenu avec ce fameux passage
sur les lois liberticides
effectivement elles ne sont pas cités
mais depuis il ya le directeur du ccf
ainsi que madjid messaoudene qui ont dit
que c'était bien la loi de 2004 et la
lotte 2010 contre le port intégral qui
était visé donc comme voix soit disant
est liberticide
donc voilà c'est pour ça que ça fait
problème et c'est pour ça que on peut
quand même s'étonner de voir beaucoup de
dirigeants de gauche qui sont en
principe attaché à la laïcité à
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
à la liberté de conscience cautionner
quelque part cette démarche alors qu'ils
auraient pu et là c'est mon point de vue
je pense qu'ils auraient pu organiser
une marche pour dénoncer effectivement
le climat qui existe en ce moment de
haine ou de défiance à l'égard des
musulmans spécifiquement pas de toutes
les religions comme olivier brice
hortefeux il aurait pu faire leur propre
initiative ils n'ont pas fait il préfère
s'associer à une initiative qui est plus
que douteuse elle a dédié ce que vous
pensez aussi que cette initiative est en
quelque sorte discrédité par certains de
ses initiateurs alors moi c'est ici pose
problème
à différents niveaux le premier c'est le
titre un islamophobe et j'ai toujours eu
un problème avec son vocabulaire là
c'est à dire qu'on est en france que le
blasphème est autorisé en france qu on
peut critiquer une religion et que sous
ce couvert là on peut pas empêcher les
gens de pouvoir critiquer dans les
jambes d'avoir le titre le titre même et
questionne sur l'écriture liberticide je
rejoins aussi c'est qu'on a pas remettre
en cause les questions liberticide et
là-dessus il n'y a pas une réelle clarté
de la part des gens qui qui organise et
qui pose question sur l'adhésion à la
république d'adhésion règles
républicaines
ça c'est évident mais j'aimerais
soulever autre chose c'est-à-dire que je
pense que dans dans l'imaginaire
français et notamment de ceux qui
peuvent être touchées par des actes anti
musulmans et cette ambiance que vous
avez décrite dans le pays aujourd'hui je
suis pas sûr qu'ils comprennent les
nuances du débat qu'on a là en fait et
c'est à dire c'est l'histoire de sept de
ces personnes qui se sentent un climat
anti musulmans dans le pays mais qui
n'ont pas d'organisation vers lequel se
tournent et qui serait finalement en
accord avec les règles républicaines et
qui pourrait porter ce message qui règle
pourrait porter ce discours au niveau
national 10 ans on est là on a envie
d'être respecté le droit à
l'indifférence l'acte sur la mosquée est
inadmissible et et voilà on voudrait la
main j'étais toujours avec cette la
mosquée toulon mais comme d'autres de
tracts on a de bayonne pardon j'ai en
même temps que j'ai ça je vous disais
c'est pas la bonne fille mercy avec la
fondation jean jaurès on a sorti une
étude
la mercredi mercredi dernier sur le
sentiment que pouvaient avoir les
musulmans en termes de discrimination et
de rats et de racisme les résultats sont
très intéressants ans a été sorti avec
avec l'ifop il
trois grosses clés la première c'est que
les fans se sentent plus discriminée que
des hommes
ça c'est une première chose la seconde
c'est que plus on est éduqué plus on est
bac +5 et plus on a le sentiment d'être
discriminées en tout cas quand on
recherche un emploi ou quand on
recherche un logement tout à fait donc
tout ça là il n'y a pas de réceptacle
qu'ils puissent être en capacité de
pouvoir porter cette parole là et du
coup on se tourne vers des leaders qui à
mon avis ne devrait plus être dans le
paysage mais qui de fait par manque et
par vides sont là et pose un réel
problème en termes d'adhésion règles
républicaines
je vous donne le point de vue de nos
internautes qui votent en direct en même
temps qu'ils nous écoutent 76% d'entre
eux ne soutiennent pas dans le ce projet
de manifestation de dimanche contre
l'islamophobie
pardon c'est peu dire car une valentin
qui peut-être aura un point de vue à
nous donner sur ce sujet je ne m'aime
pas et voici quelques réactions celle de
citoyens payeurs qui nous dit cette
manifestation organisée par des
islamistes radicaux n'est ni crédible ni
productive mais c'est justement ce qu'il
cherche vole pas eu 34 c'est
probablement un pseudonyme nous exprime
son accord à 100% avec brice hortefeux
et nicole si nous avions organisé des
manifs à chaque fois qu'on s'était
attaqué au christianisme on aurait passé
notre temps dans la rue caroline
valentin votre point de vue je suis
assez d'accord
les deux autres intervenants viennent de
dire à ses pas sur tout mais d'abord je
voudrais réagir à la réaction de brice
hortefeux qui me semble-t-il est un
problème parce qu'il parle de il dit
cette manifestation devrait compter a
concerné toutes les attaques contre les
religions je suis désolé non en france
le délit l'aspm a été sorti du code
pénal en 1791 grâce aux lumières gaza
voltaire il est fondamental que ça reste
comme ça
peut-être qu'ils pensent eux aux actes
antichrétiens c'est un homme politique
il est censé avoir fait quelques études
avoir réfléchi à 2 min sujet en tant
qu'enseignante de l'intérieur et donc il
ne peut pas faire la confusion entre une
critique contre une religion et des
persécutions exactement des persécutions
votre les volumes effectivement c'est
d'autant plus important que
l'islamophobie
c'est un mode dangereux c'est un mot qui
est simple pour être dangereux puisque
c'est le mot de l'islamisme en fait
c'est le mot véhicules de l'islamisme
qui est très silencieux
non il existait avant sur la
colonisation il a été utilisé pendant 50
ans il est réapparu dans les années 70
pour justement pour mélanger voilà pour
mélanger ça en fait l'islam à du racisme
et pour réintroduire le délit de
blasphème
rappelons nous quand même que dans les
pays où le début de la semaine
existe il est utilisé en général pour
persécuter les minorités religieuses
donc on ne veut pas de délit de
blasphème en france
c'est d'autant plus inquiétant
d'ailleurs quand on voit que les
dirigeants de la gauche radicale
elle est fille clémentine autain et tous
les autres on a vu celui de l'efi tout à
l'heure qui parlait des actes
antisémites
clémentine autain figaro sur la taille
des figaro je crois que c'était
aujourd'hui a prétendu qu'elle le
faisait au nom de la liberté de
l'égalité et de la fraternité
mais je suis désolé c'est tu m'as cette
manifestation ne représente pas les
musulmans
elle représente simplement les musulmans
fondamentalistes il ya des musulmans qui
ne sont pas fondamentaliste qui
comprennent et qu'ils connaissent
culturellement quasiment le danger du
fondamentalisme et qui déteste discours
ils peuvent aussi se dire c'est vrai
qu'il ya un climat anti musulmans anti
musulmans attendait bout d'un moment il
ya une réalité sociologique qui est ou
qui n'est pas ok on a un ministre de
l'intérieur qui est ministre des cultes
et qui réunit les actes anti-musulmans
malheureusement elle le fait quelquefois
sur la base des chiffres du collectif
contre l'islamophobie en france dont la
proximité avec les frères musulmans peut
être dit
depuis le procédé est belle car si
google a gagné parce que précisément
elle en avait fait état d' oncle cc y
est
ce sont les frères musulmans les frères
musulmans qu'est ce qu'ils veulent ils
veulent mettre une société islamique sur
orbite dans les sociétés occidentales
commencent qu'ils s'y prennent ils sont
ici prennent pour en essayant de
convertir les gens culturellement à
l'islamisme ils s'y prennent par
l'ajustement l'augmentation de la
visibilité du voile sur les musulmans
les musulmans et puis il ya quand même
chez les musulmans une dimension
clanique très fortes qui existent même
avant l'islam qui fait qu'on ne peut pas
critiquer l'islam les musulmans etc
mais cette à cet égard d'ailleurs
l'étude de la formation jean jaurès à
mon avis pose un problème parce que les
tuiles la fondation jean jaurès
elle parle des sentiments d'être
sentiment anti musulman qu'elle présente
comme des faits mettant des ont peu
comment est ce qu'on peut savoir si on
est dit
oui le ressenti ça suppose en fait dire
40 pourtant des musulmans se sentent
discriminés
moi je me sens or une autre celle de l'
agence européenne des droits de l'homme
de 2017
elle a posé les questions du ctif
retrace effectif donc on ne peut pas se
fonder là dessus ça donne la simple
citation de la sensation comme
d'ailleurs cette manifestation cherche à
le faire ça donne la sensation que la
france est un pays structurellement
franco fois par des lois liberticides et
que la population est raciste
ce qui n'est pas vrai mais ceci n'est
pas l'amérique un mode réponse peut-être
elle a dit non mais vous diront peu de
les deux chiffres en chef du pays t on
peut donner c'est le front de la une
étude seront stratégiques d'il ya un an
qui vont sur les dents dans la question
la question la question combien la
question pour moi nomination à la
question pour moi est de trouver les
outils qui ne permettent pas à cet
islamisme radical de se développer en
fête et notamment qu'il ya dans la
communauté musulmane bien soit là et
donc s'il sait le meilleur chemin et
d'anciens et de ne pas être à l'écouté
de ce que cette entre guillemets cette
communauté ressent et la façon de les
traiter dans ce pays à mon avis est une
erreur fondamentale est une erreur qui
va dans le sens des vies tellement elles
sont ressentis et fondée aussi sur ses
connaissances et si on lui dit que ses
copains musulmans sont discriminés
du coup on est discriminante merci karl
valentin guillaume bernad ce qu'on
relève c'est que cette initiative divise
la gauche et par la droite pourquoi
parce que je crois que essentiellement
la gauche un problème évidemment avec la
question de l'intégration la question de
l'assimilation la question de
l'appartenance culturelle parce que le
mot islamophobie cette amo valises c'est
un mot piège il peut recouvrer plein
deux notions différentes et d'ailleurs
les organisateurs de la manifestation en
profite
ça peut être la discrimination supposé
ou réel ça peut être les actes
d'agression réel je rappellerai quand
même que d'enfants dans le monde entier
la religion qui est la plus persécutée
c'est quand même la religion chrétienne
et pas l'islam et en france la majorité
des actes de dégradations de lieux de
culte de cimetières etc
c'est quand même les
chrétien qui les subissent beaucoup plus
que les musulmans
autrement dit ils essayent de créer une
situation où dans le fond la simple
demande d'appartenance au corps social
d'appartenance culturelle au camp social
et pas simplement de se soumettre aux
lois de la république loi qui peuvent
varier d'un moment à un autre
le simple fait de demander à une
population de ne pas être une communauté
mais d'être lié culturellement à la
france leur apparaît comme étant une
agression c'est ça le fond du problème
est donc effectivement la gauche une
partie de la gauche a accepté l'idée du
communautarisme
tandis qu'on peut penser
qu'effectivement la droite soit est
peut-être un peu moins je dirais le
coloré ou colonisés si josi
intellectuellement par set par set par
cette démarche la réalité de l'islamo
gauchisme qui avait pu être dénoncée par
un certain nombre de personnes là on
commence à le voir est réellement et
très concrètement et on verra dimanche
ce que cela va rassembler de personnes
dans la rue mais il est certain que la
cohésion du corps social est
incontestablement en danger on verra ça
effectivement